this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses
viewer discretion is advised hello hello
Jambo Jambo and a very good afternoon
from the Masai Mara triangle in Kenya
and welcome to our drive of what we call
our Sunset Drive and as you show my name
remains the same my name is David good
afternoon everyone and on come with me
is Archie Archie good afternoon and
Archie's just they're saying stop
talking to me and concentrate on the
elephants now a very warm welcome again
and we're very excited to have you
onboard today this is how we set up our
drives in the Mara it's such a glorious
view and having elephants on the horizon
it's such a nice clear blue sky on this
afternoon which I guess is a Sunday with
some very good temperatures I would say
it's not hot but for me this is pretty
one because we are talking of 80 degrees
Fahrenheit and also like the electric 27
degrees Celsius now remember our drive
is very interactive so we like hearing
or we love hearing from you so should
you have any questions any comments as
you sure throw them in hashtag Safari
live on Twitter now I have left the camp
a little bit actually because I have a
plan I won't look for the sausages so
today's particular print of lions that I
love I was here yesterday
and I was able to see three of those
gals and I was also lucky to see three
of the little caps they got I didn't see
them very well it was getting very dark
and because we have been having some
race in this area I had to leave them
alley and head back to camp
so I have come early today so that I can
see them in wonderful light and most
likely all of you will have great views
of these three small little Cubs and of
course a lot of other good things I'll
be saying well this afternoon is not
only me who is out here during the
Safari the gentleman would like also to
say hello but his Oh
we in South Africa good afternoon
everybody and welcome to Juma Game
Reserve in the sabi sands and South
Africa
David is art with me and we are trying
to capture a couple of butterflies from
the vehicle oh hello there we go it's
like I don't know what it is but it is
in a buffalo thorn there's about 50
butterflies that have been flapping
around and doing their thing good
afternoon my name is Steve and I'm
joined by Adebisi
on camera and what can I say who doesn't
like butterflies let's see if we can
capture them again but this very
important time of year what the flowers
are coming through and well the flowers
are providing lots of nectar and pollen
for all sorts of insects and as you can
see butterflies and many of these trees
would actually have been a larval food
there is a black and white pie butterfly
which is normally associated with the
buffalo thorn not necessarily for the
pollination but as a larval food they
lay their eggs on here I'm not sure if
anybody knows what these greenish
butterflies white green ones are I can't
really get a proper look at them and I'm
not an expert at looking at them from
the outside so they are when their
proboscis going down enjoying the sweet
nectar of the buffalo thorn flowers
which are very very sticky and obviously
very sweet a beautiful treat from even
blends in with the leaves doesn't that
David actually assumed you know one I
thought our that's a leaf and while it
turned out to be a butterfly but these
trees are very important larval food for
many insects and while most trees are
our Chet and I'm going to be carrying on
with a little bit of my ecology talk
from this morning and I'll be catching
up with a few people to make sure you
understood or if you missed out and
we'll see if we can keep it going mrs.
lapping who doesn't like a butterfly and
he's a very nondescript little greenish
runs I'm sure someone out there
butterflies really well would only take
a glance to see that exactly what it is
but when I talk about larval food that
means that when a butterfly or moth lays
their eggs on a tree and the next season
with the rains those
hatch and the caterpillars grow through
many stages until they eventually become
a butterfly and specific generally there
are very specific trees that certain
butterflies will use to lay their eggs
on we spoke about one or two this
morning and I hear the buffalo thorn a
plethora of insects and beetles
generally moving through but obviously
we are also going to be heading through
to see if we can find a dead
Steinbach being looked after by Hosanna
and but on the way I'm going to make
sure to finish off my ecology talk from
it this morning but in the meantime
let's go over to Sydney from Alana cozy
look at the beautiful skies you can see
that the rain is promising to come and
feel all of the dams here by the western
side of the greater Kruger National Park
Juma Game Reserve this is Sydney former
and my cozy and most of all welcome to
the beginning of our afternoon Safari my
plan this afternoon is quite very easy
I'll be looking for the general game
specifically on top I'm having the
spotted cats
Tinh Ghana my favorite Leopard I'll try
by all means and get hold of him this
afternoon you can talk to us while
looking for these animals by following
us on YouTube chat stream on South
ashtec Safari live you can also follow
us on YouTube chat stream
so I am right by the western side by the
edge of the game reserve where we have
last seen who come early yesterday I
want to see if there are no changes
there as this morning I was lucky to
come across the hyenas coming from this
direction holding a kill I don't know if
the kill was taken down by Hawk amore
and there's also the female tracks which
has been spotted a Lea or and suspicions
are linked to a shedule in the area as
she drew and who koumori they are always
for each other
so I will be looking for those kind of
evidence shed if maybe this book was not
in the area this more
well ladies and gentlemen apologies for
Sydney having some technical hitches
there sometimes these gremlins will come
once in a while we come to all the way
from Africa's wilderness and once in a
while we get a few challenges to get you
to a screen in your living room so
you'll forgive us for that it happens
once in a while and I was talking
earlier of the plans that I got for you
today and the plants have for you today
is to look for a particular pride of
lions that is called Sauceda tree now I
want to tell you why we call it the
source of the tree because I want to
show you how a Sauceda tree looks like
and it's just get a little bit windy I'm
not sure where this wind came from but
in a few seconds you'll be seeing a tree
and that tree is what we call a
certainty tree now when it fruits you
can see those fruits hanging down there
or up there rather and they take the
shape of a sausage and that's why we
call this tree this is a tree now the
substitute fried we have been following
it for a very long time and on many
occasions we have found those girls
especially the females of our bride
climbing this particular tree not this
one in particular but a similar one tree
to this one I'm sorry I missed you there
em and because they would love either to
climb this tree or to stay under the
tree because of enjoying the shade we
named that particular pride the sausage
a true pride I hope that makes sense
well our price here of lions will always
name them because of their behavior and
very true you're very good I'm you say
to those looks like cucumbers and you
remind me of a teacher when I was in
high school who could not say cucumber
but he kept
- Chamba and he was a Spanish teacher
and I think the sea and the CH were
rather difficult for him to say cucumber
and Xiu chamber well that is how a
sausage tree looks like
and I'm saying we'll name our trades
here because of their behavior and also
by how they look like now of that pride
there's one particular female that we
call the kink film King King tail King
tell because she got a split something
large or on her tail and of course we
have named have a king term then this
also another particular female in the
same pride that when she walks she limps
and we call her Limpy so depending on
their behavior and how they look like
that's how we name our animals cosmogony
asking whether you can
eat the fruit we can but we think
locally here that fruit does not have
any nutrition you but to the birds the
animals here that will eat that fruit
I'm talking about elephants I'm talking
about giraffes because it's very useful
for them before digestion
I highly doubt they get a nutritional
values from it just like us but locally
here in the villages we come from will
use the fruit - from it some look wine
today's we have big celebrations
weddings or when we have very good
harvests and we have little good crop at
the end of the year we'll always have
celebrations and of course our
celebrations is a lot of barbecue meat
and a lot of wine drink and the wine we
make will use that particular fruit to
ferment it but ideally we do not eat it
but again as I said giraffes elephants
and occasionally baboons we have seen
them eating that fruit and I guess they
eat it because it has a lots of fiber in
now this is that tough
I love playing and I'll say 9 out of the
10 times I've been in this area have
always found their sausage tree pride
and I'm hoping today will not be a
disappointment
it shall be similar to what our being
going through so we'll always keep our
eyes open we we've got four eyes mine
and our cheese and I'm sure steep in
South Africa is equally working very
hard I'm not really working that hard
David well to be honest the cause
driving itself in the riverbed well
sausage treats you want to know about
sausage cheese do you well I think all
of your viewers are just going up to
tune in tomorrow morning for what is
called medicinal Monday's and I will be
focusing on the one and only sausage
tree that we have in Juma private game
reserve yes tomorrow morning
it's very nice tree lots and lots of
history behind them and lots and lots of
interesting cultural stuff so what I'm
doing is we're down in the river I spoke
this morning a depth about the Catena
and the Catena is essentially the soil
profile a soil landscape that you find
in granitic sandy soils like Juma and
essentially the top of the landscape has
got large leaves for pumping the water
from deep underneath and the mud slope
we get the silver class leaf band and
then it goes further down slope then you
get sort of a little bit of a mixed
woodland and then some Gauri's magic
quarries and the like which then
indicates another sea plant and so deck
areas and then you get basically the the
riparian vegetation which is what we're
driving through right now it's made up
of many many tall trees habitat trees
jackal berries lead words obviously
there's lots of tambuti
so some of the trees are quite palatable
and quite tasty some of them are fruit
providing some of them are extremely
poisonous an extreme
toxic but all them so the purpose in the
landscape and the soil here because you
can imagine this was a river and above
it was deposited and the rivers the last
thing where the movement huge amount of
deposit happen here and actually just
off on my right the lying granite that
has been exposed by the passage of the
river you can see it there it's quite
coarse-grained if you look closely
you'll actually be able to see coarse
quartz crystals will be feldspar and
possibly some mica now some people
believe these granite deposits will not
deposits but intrusions date back about
two billion years on the geological
timescale and what has happened above
that is that the Earth's sediment so
here came up from magma because granite
as magma came up from underneath and the
earth deposited and deposited there was
all of the sediment and an above and the
magma stopped there and what's happened
over a very very long time this has
eroded down and here we can see it that
was once very deep in the Earth's
underneath the Earth's crust and now
here it is by the river so you can
imagine the sediment that's moved around
here an apposite across the landscape
has come from far and wide and so
there's all different types of things
but what we get mostly in general down
here in the river is this very coarse
sandy soil so not very nutrient rich but
it's quite heavy so it doesn't move that
far where is the clay stuff much more
clay rich soil which is generally
crusted on top of the the sandy stuff
it's much finer coarse grained the stuff
travels down the landscape down from the
slopes as well and further down the
river then the sand generally does sorry
I didn't get that M and so essentially
you get all different mixtures of
nutrients down here but the soil here is
invariably quite deep and there is
access to water
elephants know that P heart there could
be gold well not right here
it could be you you need to find
specific minerals in the soil to know
gold there's specific minerals that
geologists
set with gold and well I can't tell you
that
otherwise I'm giving away a trade secret
I don't honestly know the top of my head
but what you get yet in this river
system is tall trees with very very deep
roots to be able to tall as they do they
need to have as much access under the
ground as they are capable to grow above
ground so it's very very common place to
find really tall jackal berries really
tall Edwards and the like Sycamore figs
what else am I missing a nice big some
booties some big apple leaves even some
tortured smart move down to the strange
system and well they are perfect habitat
trees not only do they stand for very
long time
they obviously create nest in cavities
holes for birds
obviously that a lot of them are
fruiting so there's feeding for all
sorts of monkeys apes birds many of them
also larval food once again for
caterpillars and insects and we look at
a tree just like this jackal berry you
can almost imagine that from the root
layer underneath the ground all the way
to the top branch is a stratification of
where different species can occur when
we look at the top of the Catena the the
trees are quite sort of homogeneous in a
way we get some big marilla's which are
very important but then a few bush
willows around but none of them really
get to this sort of size so there's so
much space on a tree like that for
they're really really small the macro
level and obviously things bigger than
the macro level feed and it's this whole
trophic level that moves up and all of
that it's caused by this very nice
sediment or alluvial soil that we find
on the side of the river and obviously
these big trees are aimed at holding the
roots and holding the soil together and
preventing erosion but this is all
natural and part and parcel of the
geological time we have and the Mara has
got some interesting and sensational
geology as well are thoroughly enjoyed
my time up day
- Elizabeth in almost everything with
you here and do my in-service outside of
the acquitted Kruger National Park but
number one as you saw earlier when we
started the show the landscape here it's
more open its small vast we don't have
the thick vegetation like you knows what
Stephen Sydney got in South Africa and I
would say I want a dominant habitat here
[Music]
and that shows the amount of greens we
got here so this microphone why should
be that's how my makeup on each fall is
hiding and I think I have to make my
heart a little bit smaller it's pretty
windy here and two days ago
yes I think I'm back in business now so
I just need to plug in my Mac again and
I think I'm all set my apologies for
that and that was me without the heart
and the apologies just getting very
windy here and I'm not even sure what I
was talking about and I'm trying to
think I was talking about the vastness
of the Mara I was trying to explain what
Savannah is so the the one is an open
grassland like this year and a Juma we
have vegetation that's a lot thicker
than here here in the Mara you could
look straight like almost 10 kilometers
or let me say you can look all the ways
it's it to the horizon I give an example
of what I'm talking about and you can
see straight order the horizon without
what I call visual pollution even a
thing you'll see you might only see one
to here or one tree there now just look
at that and don't worry about the clouds
that doesn't mean we'll have any rains
but that is the difference and you can
see an elephant miles and miles away and
believe you me and I want to challenge
Steve and sitting on this you will not
see that in Juma so here you can't see
an elephant and guess that elephant I'm
extra estimating it to be about what a
kilometer two kilometers away from where
we are we have such a powerful camera
and apart from that elephant which is I
would say giving us a bit of visual
pollution and that tree you can see all
the way to the horizon one made a
difference between juma and the Mara
triangle how beautiful start some very
heavy clouds building up there we have
been going through some rains here over
the last few weeks very heavy rains
which were meant to be the short rains
but to me they have been like you know
long rains and see the beautiful or the
beauty of the savanna all the trees you
see there we couldn't tortured trees
very iconic here in the Mara and also in
certain Goethe National Park in Tanzania
so the squad made a difference between
us and seve Samms look at that so like
that elephant it picked there imagine a
giraffe walking across there and for us
I'd say it's a lot easier to uh support
cuts here than in Juma because we can
use our file you because I'm talking
about or binocular cease to look
distances and pick them of course they
would blend it very well in a place like
that but should they be walking is easy
also for us to spot them
should you see vultures for example on
certain trees like those ones up here
the laws give us some little clue there
could be some cuts there so that's the
one with the difference between where we
are and where Stephen didn't are but of
course you got areas they're good for us
and some areas also that got Cleaves
here's mountain rivers Springs and all
those different habitus well that's a
fixed not very bad for you to have an
idea of the habitat that we got tomorrow
it's a different than in Juma but I
think Steve have gotten you see of some
kind of predator well indeed we do this
animal has come from somewhere muddy I'm
not sure exactly when dams is just
behind us and this hyena is drooling a
little bit I'm not quite sure what it's
looking for it's obviously gonna walk
straight behind us start but almost
thinks like maybe it's anticipating to
see somebody wonder their sense of smell
is very acute and it can probably I'm
just going to move back there Davi get
your nice shot sorry folks I'm just
gonna have to start the vehicle to move
back
a little bit of an Edward tree behind me
here through the gap now we often find
hyenas leading us to predators and for
them to be up and mobile at this time of
day it is 33 degrees Celsius 82 degrees
Fahrenheit it is warm
obviously he's enjoying himself with a
little bit of mud hello no this is your
second favorite animal what is your
favorite animal I mean is a very
interesting I wouldn't say they're my
favorite out of my funding absolutely
fascinating but they're not my favorite
they're just really intriguing I find
their behavior and everything about them
are really really interesting okay well
I think we go back around into the
drainage that Darby what do you reckon
see what that animal is up to because it
doesn't seemed to be it seems to be in a
little bit of a mission we are making
our way slowly to the little cheese or
sauna see if he's still there I'm pretty
sure he will be at some point if not
there right now maybe he came all the
way here to twin dams for a drink this
is the place of we found him in many
times I do think that he was closer to
Chitra so if I were him I would have
gone to chit rather you know the water
is a lot cleaner that side we just go
back down into this little drainage line
and so James Richard has confirmed that
those butterflies were in fact called
African vagrants which I'm not too sure
how how familiar they are but they
surely are in huge abundance at the
moment obviously all the eggs hatching
at the same time we did find a lot of
their caterpillars art on the on the
peanutbutter cassia on one of the bush
walks apparently those are African
vagrants and while they have certainly
become a butterfly's very very quickly
and well we know a lot of the birds that
have come down from Europe or Africa
most of the cuckoos all the Cuckoo's are
specifically caterpillar feeders that's
what they eat and well all those
caterpillars feeding on all these
ginormous larval trees if you have a
look at this tree here you can see how
all the end of the leaves have been
eaten and that is from the larval stage
probably from a mini mini caterpillars
absolutely stripping this jackal berry
to the bones that is what happens sorry
Davi I'm just gonna quickly move her out
and see if we catch up with this very
dirty high you know but in the meantime
an animal that enjoys the water will the
matter as much as the hyena is with a
zoo see this is Sydney you can see those
big animals which can be able to live in
both water and on land during the day
mostly you see him in water soon as the
Sun Goes Down you will see him outside
going for some foraging purposes these
kind of animals unfortunately they are
not carnivores they are herbivores
they've got big body sizes which needs
quite a lot of grass nutritious grass
maintenance and the nutritious grass for
them to get hold of them they've got to
travel long distances which can cover
sixteen to thirty kilometers every night
according to the availability of food so
you can see some of the Bears are also
feeding on him at the moment they are
cleaning some of the old dead tissues
around the wounds while at the same time
they're also picking
some of the cheeks so these hippos can
be able to sometimes get rid of these
ticks when they're rolling in mud and
scratch against the trees but that is
not enough some of the areas are
inaccessible the beds got to come and
play a very important role
so the oxpeckers are helping a lot these
kind of animals yes they do also absorb
quite a lot of blood when they're
cleaning this kind of animals but
animals they do get quite a lot of
benefit from this kind of animals why
because the dead tissues and everything
will then cause infections and some of
the things will also attract the Flies
it's very rare to see these animals
followed by the Flies because this best
care always there and just think about
the design of the hippo tail if the hip
has got that kind of a tail which cannot
even reach anywhere these Bears are
playing a very important role when it
comes to the cleaning of the
hippopotamus it's just lying down on the
side now you can see that oh now he's
becoming active it's just changing the
side look at that this is beautiful the
nose is underwater you can just be able
to hold the breath for just about
approximately 5 to 6 minutes they look
very much calm but I can promise you a
hippopotamus is one of those animals
which can be very much potential
dangerous when he is on land they are
very territorial and they can be very
much aggressive
so these hippopotamus were seeing here
has been seen quite a lot just all by
himself is one of the solitary hippos he
is not part of any school around here at
the moment as the hippopotamus are
residing by the cheetah cheetah whatta
haul her scuba Steve is very much
popular by that gnome so the scuba Steve
is a very best friend of my colleague
Steve let's see another Steve very nice
links it is much better than my last one
a little bit of a tongue two-step anyway
we've managed to track the Tsarina
and it's got what looks to be a Spartan
David's water bottle just exploded it
seems to be a vertebrae and very hard
for me to tell you what animal but hyena
and which is very very muddy and very
dirty you know are known to cache their
certain caucuses and bones in water and
in muddy wallows to retrieve later and
it does seem like it is a bit dirty
doesn't it Davi maybe he went in to go
and find it somewhere and then it's not
come off quietly to eat definitely
desperate times lead to desperate
measures seems to be a female hyena
no it looks it looks absolutely
disgusting but that is the role of hyena
in the landscape to break very very
powerful bones and while to get the
nourishment out of them and that's one
of the reasons why I ena can lactate for
as long as they do to provide the
necessary milk very nutrient rich milk
for their their pups or Cubs due to the
fact that they get so much bone in their
diet while in the Mara and here the
animals are able to feed on bones long
into seasons when food is a bit more
scarce and can really maximize the the
animal itself whereas lion and leopard
do they have to leave so much behind you
know why we regard them as a scam
down here there are very big scavengers
up in the Mara though very very
versatile hunters as we have seen but
they will often also feed on bone
because they can and so whenever you
find an animal feeding on bone you must
think ah stolen it from someone or it's
feeding on the scraps well that's
because the scraps are there and why go
and hunt when you've got food in the
fridge in this case in the muddy water
pond to make it go rank very good
yes you can hear the sound it is very
powerful part most powerful jaw bite of
all the Predators for their body size
and they've got a very long ridge on the
top of their head for attachment of
those powerful muscles
very nice please feel free ladies and
gentlemen Center your questions and
comments hashtag a Safari live let us
know how you're doing and well also tend
to through some comments we'd love to
hear from you also you can throw them on
the YouTube chat stream right now we on
that sort of little level area that
leads down to the river so the tree
vegetation here it's quite pushy the
River Rhine area as it sort of goes from
it but more open area to bit more
thickets this is the habitat of Impala
and the edge specialists and the niala
in the edges itself inside the thickets
de coeur as well through Archer and this
is the area that the leopards love to
frequent because obviously all those
animals are their primary food source
and while they like to hide in the
thickets and that's why how they've
evolved to camouflage themselves and
because the habitats they've evolved in
is how they have learned how to survive
now you know obviously being the most
versatile of the high anyday and cooing
in many many landscapes across the
continent being very very dominant over
their counterparts the spotted horse
sorry the strap training which occurs
north of their location and then also
are competing in the brown and I unit
when they do occur in the same area odd
wolf as well part of the family not a
carnivore though completely at the mercy
of the very socially structured hyena
well it seems like a surf is up at
before sook watering hole and let's go
see who's riding the wave so you can see
that scuba Steve has got some
beneficiaries you can see the therapy is
now climbing on top of the hippopotamus
in order to enjoy him or herself you can
see the very long neck which is coming
out that is one of the features you can
use in order to distinguish between the
turtles and the Terrapins so the turtle
is the we draw their head sideways
whereas the toe toe is they will draw
their back straight and the turtles can
be able to hide it deep inside the shell
so both turtles and therapies they've
got strong shares so you can see that
only one is coming out at the moment but
sometimes you'll find Scuba Steve with
quite a lot of turtles on top of him a
lot of Terrapins on top of him
it's pretty relaxed so I just want to
see what is going to happen I can hear
those birds the oxpecker still flying in
the area if they're going to go back
again and join the Terrapin you can see
it's not worried it means there is a
nice dependency between these two
and these is a very much cute
Oh ever seen that I've just said it now
have you seen how that Terrapin dived
back into the water wall for safety so
that Terry really just dropped when that
oxpecker was bending I hear the
oxpeckers making noise up in the air and
then one of them dive back was not even
worried about the Terrapin and the
Terrapin just went back to their water
hole so they are back again trying to
clean the wounds
so these he Papa Thomas is looking very
much small there but I can promise you
when this hippo is out
he won't believe is so huge can be up to
1,700 kilograms now let's go to the rear
Steve from Scuba Steve thanks it is not
far away
Oh should I say you're in the north of
Jummah we're at in the South twin dams
here before look we're still with this
hyena and if we have a listen let's see
if we can hear the bones crunching
very powerful jaws and they don't even
need to use the side of their jaw the
side of the teeth the carnassial's share
that you find in all predators the
hyenas molars on the side which are very
very sharp and very bone crushing
extremely powerful and a regarded is the
strongest teeth in nature crocodiles are
able to replace their teeth hyena or not
so they need to be able to crush bones
for most of their life it's about to
survive it's one of the reasons that
they are able to survive and so many
diverse habitats
ah guys have a look at what we've just
found I told you the little chief will
just come and say hello you'll just come
and say hello Barbara I'm sorry I'm
going to answer your question in a
minute but husana has decided to come
and give this heinous spanking and this
is awesome
Barbara hyenas by scatters white because
of the bone and the diet when they're
dropped there scattered actually is
green and it goes white as it as it sort
of calcifies and dries so that is a
testament to the amount of David was
just a kid come on turn around Steve and
I was like why and here's a sana he's I
told he's gonna come and say hello
didn't I he's he was on his way to come
and drink it twin dams and he heard the
crunching okay so there's a couple other
people that were looking for a son and
they've gone to the sighting so I'm just
gonna quickly let them know while you
enjoy watching this beautiful creature
coming up a closer I'm going to actually
keep quieter for a second because this
could be interesting Davi I'm gonna stay
right about Hannah thinks there's
something he wants but it's a vertebrae
not what he wants
one word tweet everybody what do you
think about this let's see if he's gonna
give him a hiding I'm not going to start
the car
I think invite some people on board most
certainly him
good afternoon and a very warm welcome -
from Juma private game reserve in South
Africa where we stumbled across a hyena
that was busy feeding on probably some
very old bones that have cashed my name
is Steve I'm joined by Java C dot camera
and we were actually planning on going
out this afternoon to look for this male
leopard who has just stumbled across us
we were talking about aa hina and the
color of their dung and while there is a
leopard my favorite delivered the little
chief who's not gonna suddenly realize
that the bones are that he is about to
look at are actually really gross and
only capable of being broken by a jaw
from a hyena of that ilk lion had
absolutely no idea
hello well Silas hello to everybody if
you have questions comments throw them
in on the chat stream below up to hear
from you hello pet you think he's hungry
well we found this morning on a Stan
Walker kill and well people have gone in
the directions to see if they can find
him we decided to follow the hyena
because we thought maybe it would lead
us to or so notice something of interest
and well did indeed it did indeed lead
us there how awesome is that
well I just love this guy he is such a
character he knows we've got a TV show
this evening and he wants to be a
superstar here he is
look at that beautiful face now he's
probably gonna go to the dam and have a
drink that's really crazy it's have been
walking at this time of debt a Ricardo I
think most people's favorite feed line
is a leopard definitely well are we
gonna see if we can follow him I think
that action Fort Lee High in here is
over he's gonna go down and have a drink
we're gonna see if we kept keep up with
him there were some y'all that just over
here that we saw so maybe
he's still here Emmys right yeah in the
thicket and he looks like he spotted
something
we did have some yalla that we saw just
before we came up yet and a very nice
little little pathway into the bushes
yet it is 33 degrees Celsius about 83 so
Fahrenheit and well to find it leopard
moving around in this time of day he
must be very thirsty
I don't think he's talking but he might
and they were some Yana on her way up as
I said and while he is definitely
spotting something over there
we're just above a dry riverbed so this
is the perfect habitat for the
camouflaged niala day cap and push back
the edges also quite commonly used to
buy him pilot and what there's the
perfect habitat for stalking cat reman
no he's not limping he's just stalking
he was doing the leopard walk doing the
leopard walk oh he's just in that think
it's dead I'm not getting the best view
of him
ah breathtaking indeed well we are super
blessed with the superstar of a cat well
that's that last view we're gonna have
to get of him now his is a flat though
it's definitely having a look at
something that might just be down the
drainage here it definitely will be able
to get around in a moment remember folks
this is coming 200% live from and the
greater Kruger National Park in drama
and well please we would love to hear
from you just throw any comments or
questions down below or sign up and
their little chief mmm Linda you are
spot on me is a very beautiful get and
while he is definitely on the move now
look at the body language the body
posture changing
hello Ruth leopards mail leopards
normally between 10 and 13 is a good
good age from a leopard due to the
competition that they experience females
can live up to 15 maybe even a little
bit more in the wild in captivity they
have been known to live much longer due
to the fact that there's not as much
fighting in danger but Archer we've got
a male leopard his father and who's in
his thirteenth year we thought he was
ailing early this year and he sprung
right back again so there's another
female who's 12 so that's you don't
generally I've never come across you
only come across leopards that are older
than that in the wild but almost always
cases that it might happen but he
definitely looks like he's interested in
something that's just there in the
thicket I'm gonna see if I can just get
around yeah there's a little bit of a
clearing just around the corner Dave
now see you want to know if lipids and I
heaters generally come to cut clothes
well essentially oh I think I've got a
stump in front of me I'm going to have
to go back mass what we find here is
that the hyena follow the lepers around
and there's a huge competition between
the two for food resource obviously they
feed on very similar food and the
leopard being a very good hunter often
horse Anna has lost out to his prey
via hyena his dad though steals a lot
more of it as well so he's a very young
leopard he's only turning 3 in February
and well he's done very well this year
we've had an absolutely incredible year
with him looking very intently into the
bushes there Georgia yes most certainly
those powerful jaws of the high unit
which are designed for crushing and
breaking bone if he bit horse Anna on
the leg broke a leg broke a ligament did
any damage to him physically could lead
to his starvation a leopard that cannot
climb a tree will not be able to hunt
will not be able to escape predators
will not be able to hoist their kills so
essentially it could lead to their
demise
so essentially leopards which are on a
weight level more powerful than I mean
a--from a physicality point of view one
bite from Mahina could lead to his death
in the long run so they avoid them if
they can't now but leopards develop sort
of a reputation with i-n and we've seen
him many many times running from them
and he's starting to really stand up for
himself when it comes to one hina but
when there's more than one well the new
junior turns tail and runs cuz that's
just an unfair fight
I didn't have myself in her son a very
stealthy well I try
gone same as stealthy as this young dude
is he snuck up on us they had no idea he
was coming you sneaking up on the hyena
just goes to show how brazen he is he
wasn't bothered with one eye Internet he
thought he might be able to steal some
food for me but what has he spotted look
at the excitement look at the excitement
of his his tail there
Ruth you wanna know if this is in color
this is a 100% color and we are in the
summer months we've had some rainfall
watch out folks he looks like he's about
to launch we're just gonna stay right
here for a second
urologists alarm called did you hear
that bok dimmer he is different poking
up this and yalla they've spotted him
city boy you've been spotted that's one
thing he needs to work on his stealth
and while his patience it's within Jana
that we saw before and well he's not
going to walk very nonchalantly past him
as if he didn't care in the world at all
well folks as wasana goes down to the
watching hall to have a drink the jnanis
seemed to be safe for the moment i hope
you've enjoyed this little moment with
us please feel free we are still after
another hour or so just Google Safari
laughs thanks for your questions and
comments and we'll see you next time
have a good day
welcome back everybody I just need to
that other gentleman that I'm working
with this morning this afternoon know
that we have managed to find the little
chief and also try not to dive into this
little knob thorne session so we've
relocated on hasanah
and here's know about towards twin dams
they'll get people excited or going off
there okay well we had a muddy hyena
with some very disgusting looking bones
the little chief on his way to drink and
well Sydney has got a hyena of his own
you can see that I've got the lovely
hyena who is now just having a mud bath
this Ayana just got into this water now
just about a minute ago we found him
lying down and I varnish shade but you
can see that his multitask is inside
there but the nose is still getting
information from the air particles this
is what the highness mostly do when it's
too hot at the moment the Sun is
increasing a little bit yes now is
towards the sunset but it's still very
much warm here where I am at the moment
so hyenas also el in the mornings you
will see them going to the water holes
indeed this is a brilliant moment look
at that
you will see them - in the morning
chasing each other playing inside the
water holes as well highness
they eat carry-ons and it's not very
often that you will see you will pick
them up with that kind of a distance if
smell from those Koreans because they
come and bath so they but all the time
you can see this whole body is right
deep there so this must be helping them
as well in order to get rid of the
parasites so high infestation of the
parasite gives this animals a problem
specifically when the is shortage of
water
as dehydration can be a very serious
threat to the animals the ticks do
absorbs quite a lot of blood from the
animals and because of that they
experienced dehydration so so far I'm
just seeing just one hyena
Akane I haven't seen the Alvino hyena at
the moment the only animal white I have
seen before it was an Impala which was
completely white and I've also seen a
zebra without the stripes as well and
obvious the white lions white lions I
saw that it is caused by what is called
live system the disappearance of the
melanistic pigment the pigment which is
responsible to give these colors the
dark colors is that trees trees for them
to get these green leaves they are
relying on what is called a chlorophyll
pigments so pigments they play a very
significant role in order to create this
beautiful spots and colors we are seeing
on these animals these hyenas from the
Juma clan they do compete a lot with
some of the Predators such as this one
we have managed to relocate on the
little chief
and I think I need to get a hold of
Sydney for some good news but has heard
something on the radio that he will very
likely be able to go to warts everybody
would be very excited as well just need
to I'm not going to tell you any more
than that when we've got the little
chief of busy drinking and well how
amazing was that that he just we were
looking at I you know talking about
pooed as we do and David's like look
behind you I thought he wanted me to
look at the camera and there was the
little chief's talking nine how
magnificent so when I was discussing
earlier about thinking Chittoor was
closer as a drinking point maybe he
prefers this area due to him knowing it
better maybe he doesn't like that the
guests in room 11 anymore she trap
haven't seen them or Sunnah on that side
in some time he doesn't know it quite
well
maybe he's getting a bit more brave and
he wants to come back again to try and
compete against Hawker woody
yes please if you could I mean I'm a
short Sydney's on the radio there if he
just chats him about the access this
afternoon Emma that would be great a
very thirsty cat we've seen we often see
leopards drink I don't think they've got
the most well adapted to drinking
technique and there's a lot of mess that
goes on there
lots of drool but marvelous to be seeing
them moving at this time of day
I really didn't anticipate him to be up
and about in the heat I'm sure you're
all be all happy to hear that David and
I intend to stay with him for as long as
possible and called him in on the radio
and the people who interested in finding
him couldn't find him it is a little
spot before they've moved off to the
north so they are preoccupied with other
sightings so absolutely love the fact
that sometimes we can be with a leopard
all on our own absolutely magical and
the little chief is the most magical of
them all really is a special folks to be
able to spend time in the life of a cat
and doing what they do many of the
reserves you might go to have leopard
but they're not habituated wild skulking
animals that are very very hard to see
cuz they're very observant in theory
what's the word away and a leopard that
doesn't want to be seen well will not be
seen right yeah his way I had him come
and lie next to us one day
sorry I turned the wrong way Davi sorry
I'm a bubble girl said something there
didn't quite get it are you gonna come
sit in my shade the shades behind boy Oh
bubble girl no that watered certain is
not clean but the animals are well
adapted to drinking water that's quite
am quite rancid okay how sign are you
gonna go up there there was some a
parlor on the other side of the dam wall
yeah let's go and see if he's still
hungry after that drink you might just
plop down in the shed but he's probably
going to
okay well while we get up and see if
he's going to chase some ahi Nana Sam
Impala let's go back to sitters and his
hyena so the hyena is enjoying himself
at the moment as we even saw him falling
asleep at one stage deep in this little
waterhole
the waterhole was not created by the
hyena this is a natural waterhole
why am I saying is the national water
hole because is the result of the
elephants this has been done by the
animals let's quickly go to a sauna yes
well this could go on all day folks once
he starts hunting he never stops you can
see the Impala on the right of the
screen it house Ana's flat a couple in
part of it his looking is trying to pick
up the shape that's why when the leopard
goes up a little Ridge of termite mound
their ears go flat they changed the
shape of their body that's one of the
characteristic signs when you're looking
in the bush for cats when you're walking
is you often see this little head pop up
he's going to go to the right is gonna
try and find another spot here he comes
Ella boy are you gonna go around now the
brain is going okay wait am I gonna go
let me think about this I think there's
Impala gonna be too widely for them
there they kind of have an idea they
probably heard the bush buck earlier and
they're on the alert Impala are well
known to be what I said before edge
specialist so they like to be on sort of
the edge of the thicket sorry about my
head they on the edge of the thicket
with some open clearing on the outside
so they'll spend the night and sort of
cooler periods in the open and well when
it's hot did that go into the shaded
areas and feed on the brows and ruminate
there and it also means that they're
able to be bit more detective of a
leopard if it does happen to come past
he's gonna go all the way around the
damn wall get on to the thickets that
side and maybe see if he can try as luck
so there was a question before about the
cleanliness of the water these watering
holes are accumulated over a period of
time all sorts of algae and organic
material is in there and it's not ideal
if we drank it would probably get quite
sick but animals Archer have got a very
very well adapted stomach
we should I say filter our water and our
way to sanitary so our gut enzymes that
would normally be good at digesting and
dealing with whatever's in that water
well we've long and truly lost that in
the process of what we call civilization
leopards and animals Archer have been
drinking
very very rancid water for a very long
time and the ones that are weak well
they don't survive the ones that are
strong lived to drink another day okay
well while he moves up to that site
let's see if we can reverse back and go
get in before we lose sight of him
wonderful is this a well he's going it's
a little cave are you gonna hide in the
cave is your verse back yeah this is
exactly where I had him once to kill a
scruffy and then he sat down and we were
parked with him just now he was drinking
right there looking at me as only Hassan
and I start to look very very special
animal that we have yet
[Applause]
see these in policy how alert they are
yes he is on the mission today
I wonder what's going on I mean I think
he's still quite unsettled after
yesterday I'm no doubt to see those
Impala males a little bit out the
way there and then the open I don't
think there's any chance of a sauna
catch of them lots of boys together and
yeah he's going to do exactly what I
anticipated to hang out in the shade so
I think he's still a little bit shaken
he's just down over here we're going to
get another view of him in a second once
we link away but that's just reestablish
him there again but I think he did have
a bit of an interaction with Haku Mori
and well he's going to stay a little bit
further south from where who Komori hang
out I had anticipated yesterday maybe
finding him around treehouse dam which
is a little bit more west from where we
are now finding him here now is not
really a surprise he does know this area
quite well there's water abundance of
game to come down who koumori went and
moved past of where Telepan which has
been hassanis haunt for so long so I
think he's a bit unsettled of the
drooling evil stare of the hooker moody
himself but anyway someone who spent
most of that yesterday afternoon with
the hook himself was a Sydney
it was the fantastic yesterday seeing
who Komori by the western side of the
game reserve as we haven't seen him for
quite a long time and something else is
that now I am planning to make my way
much more towards the Torchwood there I
might be lucky with one of those lipids
we haven't seen for quite a long time
I'm talking about the leper such as
tandy Leopard such as calamba those ones
I know these days are concentrating much
more that side I have seen Colombo few
days ago but Andy it has been a while
so let's hope I find one of those
animals or all of those animals by the
good network access areas as touchwood I
know my only challenge there is poor
network access but it doesn't matter I
will go there
so I'm just I am also very much excited
about going to touch food I love going
there because it's a completely
different environment we have been to
Juma quite a lot we know all these areas
and we do see this animals a lot but
it's good at least to go there and try
something else
so I am now driving past central and
still no tracks of Tenggara
maybe is always maybe is also in the
very same area where I'm heading to
so I will be trying to heat two birds
with one stone as I indicated on my
introduction today I'm looking for a
general game could be the Lions or the
lepers any updates I'm going to follow
their videos got one of those lions
interested in climbing a one favorite
tree very good luck Sydney hopefully
gonna get us postcards because I already
got my spotless cards here I'm not sure
that causes for this cut and you just
stretch and this is the sausage tree
pride for those of you who could be
joining us now this is the pride I was
looking for and it was my main mission
when I left the camp this afternoon full
of joy to have found them and I want to
see them for a couple of minutes and
find out exactly what they do I got four
females here there's two that you just
saw and this one here I've got that they
are trying to hunt and what I just gasps
deer hunting is not anything they can
see and my apologies is a bit windy here
and I think I'm picking all the
allergens and pollen from the grass I
got a feeling the one to hunt a warthog
because I can't see the prayer the only
sensible animal I'll think they'll be
looking for is a pig and most likely
they won't hunt a warthog that reckons
it is somewhere so that female mayor is
like leading the pack she's ahead of
everybody and what I guess she will do
is to go around the Warthog and maybe
push it towards the other three wow
that's my thinking I'm sure the
lionesses have a different plan who
knows what they're thinking and the
stream of still determined Mount
and they're definitely in touch the in
communication of some sort and remember
our drive is very interactive so should
you have any questions or comments
please send them through using hashtag
myself are reliable Twitter she just
turned back to look at the camp's
because the camera not very far from
where they are and I'm sure you know
these particular prior three clubs and
have been told to stay put and don't
move stay somewhere keep playing until
we let you know so cut those two there
and that one in front there huh
and there's one more I don't know where
she is could she be four but when the
pride is together they are always five
females and the fifth female but is
missing I could be wrong but I think she
could be somewhere trying or dropping
her young ones we saw her last night and
her belly was bulging a very big belly
and I'll be surprised today or tomorrow
or maybe last night she dropped her cubs
which would be another generation good
cider you like so with the Alliance hung
around the camp yes they do and you know
what they also just hunt next door a few
weeks ago they brought down a zebra
about 300 meters from my tent yes I had
lots of movement at night and I wasn't
sure and I thought I was dreaming
because I just had something being
strangled initially there's some huge
movement and a lot of running and then
yes I'm since that's silly crazy and
then the the chase was towards or
between the camp and a little clinic we
have for this stuff there and what you
saw the following morning was the zebra
that was brought down or of course the
Lions are gone they know I mean they're
lions are equally intelligent they know
people live there they couldn't see the
Cubs to consider tent so they left and
we had hyenas then the following night
because the Highness couldn't come
during the day so yes I mean we think we
are the visitors we came where the Lions
leave so we do not blame them when they
come to the camp but yes they come close
and the times we have taken pictures of
len prints just outside like 10 10 15
meters outside your tent so that happens
many times the only thing is we'll
always have flashlights when you go out
to make sure you use your flashlight you
don't have one use your ears if you
don't you know use your eyes nicely if
you see anything moving be very careful
but yes they do come and you can't blame
them it's one particular pride that
lives very close to where we are and
it's good that all a lot of pride
this particular pride for those of you
who are joining us now is called the
sausage' trip rider five females at the
moment at three cubs v female is not
here and we think more I personally
think should be somewhere going to they
may be labor ward to bring down her cubs
tumors have been hanging around in this
Garcia that are called old Anya pipe
it's a coalition of true males would you
think are the father of the Cubs the
cabins have been left a little bit
behind by these females because they've
got plants to hunt and calves been cops
it might interfere with their hunting
with strategy so they have to be left
behind so that these females can do
exactly what they want so these slowness
is I can tell you they are hungry and
definitely either now or later tonight
or much later tomorrow morning they
might be going for a prayer to feed
themselves it's not only these lionesses
that are hungry because even Hashanah is
equally hungry thanks GG well we are
indeed with husana and he is sitting in
the open you spoke earlier about it we
wouldn't see a lip an elephant walking
through the open here well out hope you
could find a leopard walking through the
open where you are because that is what
we see commonplace yep obviously we
don't see elephants too often moving
through the open area they like to be in
thickets where they feel quite
comfortable but we do have a sign up and
he is lying flat here by the dab he eats
he's eaten probably all of his stomach
cuz no one has reported that there is
anything on site but we must follow him
back if he goes back to see exactly
whereabouts
you might be going but the fact that he
is hunting it's just Testaments to the
curiosity and opportunistic behavior
that these animals have Becky I have no
idea about my what might have happened
what I do know is that people went to go
and try and find him and couldn't find
him there was no report of the kill in
the tree and the report of another
leopard on scene so it's possible he
just got thirsty and he came down to
drink I really don't know that's one of
those things in the bush yep that the
mystery it just continues but it's very
hot and see him panting quite
deliberately now digesting his food
pushing the diaphragm up so he's not
starving
not at all starving panting away
very nice
hello Simon and yalla you want to know
how long a leopard can survive without
water well probably the same as us for
me just a few days before dehydration
kicks in but you know all mammals have
the need to drink water regularly they
probably go for I don't know three four
days we could probably go for that as
well before we had any real major side
effects but essentially leopards live in
an area where there is water they will
not spend time far away from water but
what they can do is they can get a lot
of the moisture from the blood from
animals that they do kill that's one of
the things that they can't get but the
blood is also quite salty so invariably
even though it might add the moisture
that they need
if you've ever eaten something salty
Germany leads you to get quite thirsty
so it's often you find leopards after
eating something they come and drink
lions are the same and while they'll
drink until they're full but water is
very important for all mammals we were
born in a placenta surrounded by water
and we are completely dependent on it to
for the rest of our lives there are only
a few mammal species in the world that
are really really well adapted to
surviving with very low amounts of water
and while a leopard needs to scent mark
and they urinate a proper urine stream
and just like us they have no modified
kidneys for a sort of storing or sort of
soaking out any of the moisture like
most birds and reptiles do all birds are
suppose no uric acid is secreted instead
of urine they need moisture to keep
their body processes going legal scarce
I can't even see the lion injury I
remember the story happening but I
haven't seen any markings on him he is
looking absolutely gorgeous look at him
doesn't he look like a little cuddly toy
you could just go ahead and cuddle up to
Dave oh yeah oh yeah he is ridiculous
and folks if this is your first time
watching this is a hundred percent live
wild leopard absolutely wild he is
turning 3 years
in February I'm gonna be all going to
have a really big party aunty Davi you
know we don't need any excuses but for
the little Chifa we'll have a big party
in the name for him we'll make a cake
and he could eat it we might make a
Steinbach Pie for him I think he might
like a Steinbach pie and we'll even
bottle a little bit of twin dams water
for him sorry I didn't get that him as
something about candles he's dreaming
now of his birthday horn candles yeah
you know of course some in Pilar horns
maybe Steinbach horn so peg them into
the table if you can't blow them out it
wouldn't be surprised if he arrived for
his birthday I mean look how he just
materialized behind Dave and myself he
has a knack of doing that you know folks
he has a knack of just materializing
we've got Herbie art on foot he went to
go see if he could find a signer after
someone couldn't find him he was trying
to track him another vehicle was
interested to find him and well we
decided to follow ah you know and as we
netted that I in my son had his pops out
behind which he does so many times
before beautiful
beautiful I just need to give a quick
update on the radio yes he is gorgeous
and he is really filling out now that
I've spent a few days with him really
started to see the size of the neck
there the head was sort of that sort of
that area behind the ears that sort of
top neck is really really firming out
I still got a bit of growth to do his
tracks are really nice and big but I'm
not sure how big he is compared to who
can woody at the moment who Kumar is not
a big lip that he's stocky but he's not
tall I find it in Ghana to be a bigger
looking Leopard and well this is the
product of Tenggara and I'm sure he's
going to be a very fine young he's
really fine young man the nicest
gentleman out here isn't he Davi okay
well we are not going anywhere folks
we're going to see what silliness he
gets up to there's some last cloud cover
pulling in to cool us down and in the
meantime let's go up to the sausage tree
republic with David and the sausage tree
pride I also stayed here with a sausage
a trip right particular female on top of
this diamond Mount not sure what she is
looking at because this seems or they
seem to have given up on that were
talkin either the one who went too far
and in general blind and all in
assisters fast runners me calculate and
the think is not worth the hunt or the
energy they gonna ban trying to chance
on the white oak then they miss it they
don't you don't want to just forget it
this is the fourth member of this five
counts like bleep so we call this one
here Limpy
we got Limpy there she is looking at and
Limpy got one cup with her can see the
monitor possibly got close to the couch
which are not very far from here
this lioness is to me they look hungry
and I'm sure at one point they must do
some hunting today so as try to get
close to the cab's let's go back to
Steve Mobile who still got her son with
him
[Applause]
welcome back and we're do apologize
about the technical issues faced up in
the Mara the sausage tree republic has
not always got the best signal and well
hopefully david will manage to get those
Lions to hunt in an area that is a
little bit more sort of signal friendly
barring a mite we are streaming a live
internet show to you viewers all over
the world wherever you might be sitting
and watching and while we're coming to
you from Juma in the South Africa sabi
sands and in the Maasai Mara Triangle up
in Kenya quite an amazing feat do not
ask me more about that information
because all I know is that there is a
metal rod on the back of my vehicle with
machines inside the car that make a
little bit of noise and that is all I
can tell you the rest is left up to
those those tech geniuses we have around
are you looking at the goo sauce on it
that'll be funny it'll be funny you
looking at that one Egyptian goose is
that a meal would you like to catch
yourself some goose for for New Year's
hello chilli pepper okay well if he
stops moving we might be able to show
you chilli pepper you're a new viewer
welcome to the show leopards have got
SWAT patterns on their face which is
okay guys let me show you I got a
picture on on my book yet but I can
actually show you okay so when we look
at leopards we look at this see they've
got whisker patterns yet we look at this
top line over here there's no whiskers
coming out we look on either side of the
face and we get a spot pattern so this
would be at two and I can't see the
other side there but maybe at two husana
has got a three at a three pattern on
his face he's got a very pink nose and
he is a male so we know our leopards are
quite well obviously in the beginning
takes a bit of getting used to when you
identify them Dingaan is a bit more
raggedy he's got a bit of a longer face
he's much older obviously than hasana
and he is a male as well so males are
much bigger than females and a first
glance if you are
you viewer or a new person to the bush
it's quite tricky to identify a male
versus a female leopard but when you
look at the neck the neck of the lady
think about is always very nice and
elegant nice and slim and elegant and
well they are actually much smaller than
the males
hisana a few months ago well it was
quite tricky to ID him as a male because
he didn't hadn't really filled out that
much at the time and his neck was also
quite sort of thin but he is slowly
developing the size of his father and
each leopard has got almost a unique
spot pattern and you can also then look
at marks on the ears scratches on the
face and well knows sometimes pink black
or spotted all of these things we've got
some viewers even that are able to
identify these cats are by their bottom
which I find absolutely incredible with
certain pictures of the leopard walking
away you can basically get just a little
pattern on anywhere that kind of stands
out to you and then with that you can
see also got a couple of crooks in his
ear there what a nice spot urine if the
impala come down to drink he knows it is
that Wow I've never been here before
there's a good spot and so over time you
can identify them it takes a bit of
practice but once you've identified a
few and you know what area you in you
can generally start identifying more and
more but the little chief is a superstar
and his face is on the magazine of many
here on many magazines around the world
I only Jack but many of our viewers have
been watching the show for a long time
Kasana being almost three has been on
screen almost every day for the last
three years so it's well known to many
people as is Tandy ant in Ghana and
Hassan as mama gorilla very well known
and very popular cats and the images are
burned into history with many of our
viewers who love these animals to death
and we do as well definitely very
special I mean the car camouflage he is
there hiding in the little hole hello
Holly you want to know what I mean when
I talk about sawing well Holly if
you ever gone into your dad's workshop
and he's got a big sore and he cuts a
plank of wood but I want to do two
louder because I don't want to scare him
but basically we do the plank of wood
you you pull it like this and it makes
er kind of sound and that is what we
call sawing it's something that the
Panthera genus can do lions are able to
raw leopards saw a jagger I think does
something quite similar neighborhood
when a tiger does something in that
regard as well and then it's adaptation
to the Voicebox
and sort of ligaments around the lung
and in the chest that enable them this
boom box effect which is designed for
territorial marking and also for the
attraction of mates so the sawing is an
immediate sort of sign of the animals
presence and hasanah still too young to
be sawing that might possibly be a
testosterone thing a maturity thing but
it's generally only practiced by animals
that are trying to claim a territory and
for now the little hasana the little
chief is hanging out with in his dad's
territory and trying not to attract too
much unwanted attention yesterday we
believe he nearly had a close call with
who Komori a big male from the West who
I haven't seen in some time I'd love to
see him he's a formidable looking cat
and well if he got hold of a sauna there
would definitely be some trouble but if
her sada started calling he would
immediately attract the attention of any
dominant leopard that is nearby and that
is an advert advertisement basically
like standing on top of the hill and
shouting down any challenges come
forward well you better be sure when
they come forward that you stand your
ground otherwise you will be chased if
you don't want to be seen you just keep
very quiet and skulk around within the
territory and hopefully you don't get
noticed
yeah the woodland a Kingfisher in the
background a very characteristic
summertime call
well everybody we've hopefully got some
good news for you Sydney has moved on
from his hyenas what has he got for you
I have just been to the touch wood and
I'm on my way out due to a very serious
poor network access and I was with the
little Queen
I was with Columbo by the touchwood Dam
unfortunately we couldn't manage to show
you anything there due to the bad
signals but hopefully Colombo will come
out to our side I am back again in
humour to see if I can find any other
interesting animal for this afternoon so
here I am now on cheetah cat line which
is the border between us and touchwood
here is where I normally read the
information about animal trespassing
from Juma to touch food and tortured
back to Juma I am checking to see if
Tandy is not on our side yet I didn't
see any evidence showing the presence of
Tandy in Torchwood at the moment
thank you very much chef giraffe girl
you are wet they are so encouraging I am
now going to carry on and see if I can
find you any of the other interesting
animal as I indicated is a general game
viewing this afternoon korsak's
that is true I'm owing David his lilac
breasted roller but the stage is still
on
if I find one I will show you maybe
David is going to get married soon
because Lana crested roller has got a
very interesting traditional belief
whereby the groom and the bride used the
feathers in order to build their love
lasting relationship so I have got a
very interesting animal here with me
this animal is not part of those animal
we used to see traveling with today the
world is decided to move around with the
impalas no zebras here we know that
well the beasts they do walk together
with the zebras very often but today
they are depending on the small animals
and these I can assure you has got
something to do with the poor eyesight
of the world a beast and the better
eyesight of the impalas so small animals
are benefiting the big animal it's not
always that the big animals benefit
smaller animals so that is the blue
wildebeest you can see that is looking
very much healthy why I'm saying is the
Bluebell de beast because the tips of
the horns are facing inwards and if it's
the black vote abyss as we have got to
well the Beast here in southern Africa
and the tips of the horns were going to
face like this
of the blue of the black wildebeest they
face front front ones and upwards front
was and upwards for the blue wildebeest
is just in words so that is how you can
easily
English between these two species but
looking at the tail as well this one has
got a much darker tail the black Valda
Beach has got a white tail so you can
easily see that from quite a long
distance so where the Beast they do get
preferred by the large predator such as
the Lions I'm sure they're in Masai Mara
where David is he has been witnessing
the Lions going after the worldA beast
as lions maybe can use the advantage of
their poor eyesight so you can see as
well we have got the oxpeckers on top so
they are also doing the same job they
were doing to the hippopotamus oxpeckers
they are not discriminative they just
clean all these herbivores and when it
comes to the Lions that are look at that
where the Beast is just returned by the
oxpeckers so now let's quickly go back
to the entertaining cat of the afternoon
in Duma Steve with asana well if he
wasn't breathing I think he died because
his tongue is loading out the side of
his face everybody we need to take
screenshots of this please because you
know an old man we can show him what a
city what it was when he was younger his
pulling his bit off his best cuckoo
Mauryan personation all the hukum or his
tongue normally hangs out the front of
his sana
now found a very nice cool spot that's
in the shade no doubt the soil is a
little bit cooler there
then I'll sweat and I know I had
questions the other there but why
wheredo leopards like to lie down and
well that is a very soft sort of erosion
ditch that's coming down into the
watering hole here now caused by water
moving across an area that has been over
grazed and while the soil in there has
been shaded it's probably a little bit
of moisture still from the rain we had
the other day and a perfect little place
to rest a tired and warmer body okay
well have you decided you're going to
move boy I want to lie there a little
bit more open there we go
ah isn't that the spot now that is the
photograph that people are always
looking for the majestic cat I had him
the other day I'm the termite mound
posing so beautifully for us oh the
Flies are starting to bother him you can
see that neck aren't you the julep is
starting to form when you look at a
female leopard you'll notice that that
sort of neck areas are very sleek and
very narrow because Zhanna Zhang and
well hung over from a steam box possibly
but
I mean
that most likely he was going to be
sitting and doing pretty much nothing
but we were surprised when he popped out
with us with the hyena and super
honey-nut and super blessed as well easy
but so we can get right in on that spot
pattern there Davi on the top of the lip
you can see he's got three right at the
top of the screen just behind the nose
and there's three spots there and if he
turns his head you'll see there's three
on the other side sometimes we can
identify them as well from the canines
for example say and Sandy's right right
bottom canine is blunt that's obviously
a sign of age he looks like you got a
bit of her of a cut in his lip there no
bit of loose skin
he was drooling the panting a little bit
of air moving in to cool him down but
one thing we've noticed as all the
theories about leopards cooling down
through panting and whatever has always
been quite interesting but with the
Flair that Dave likes to put on me look
at the bottom of leopards feet that is
where they lose most of their heat well
anyway a leopard is a little bit bigger
than a lion cub and they probably lose
heat a little bit slower but then they
stay warm and long into the night lion
cubs need to cuddle with mum yes I'm not
very sure lip words like the heat and
more so host Anna that's why she could
be a little lazy here but I got very
playful cards here and the three cubs
have woken up and I would say now
they're shining playing with your
mother's ass they are weaving to the
grass in the Mara Triangle in the
savanna and not sure exactly where they
want to go but we good to all the
females that have moved quite far from
this particular ones here and there
about 100 metres away and they're moving
the in turn to the - but I'm sure this
one is staying back behind to make sure
these Cubs are fine and safe now we want
to find out what strategy or what plan
or they're trying to lame but I think
the two have a plan and these are the
two females are staying behind for those
of you who could be joining us now this
is the sausage' trip ride
and I got a feeling these lionesses
are hungry the bellies don't look very
full there's one particular one that we
called kinked L because she got hit a
split on her tail she looks big her
belly's so massive but that there that
she is but that's doesn't mean she is
full of thing cause she is pregnant and
she'll be bringing her cubs anytime
maybe in a couple of few days to come
and I'm looking at that's more so during
the new year so it could be having new
year with new Cubs time will tell the
other females missing here I had the
very wrong predictions two weeks ago and
I kept saying next week new Cubs next
day new Cubs tomorrow new cards it never
happened I was with her last night and
she was still very pregnant
today she's missing Jasmine how are you
today and yes I can tell you baby
sausages have made my day and hopefully
I gonna continue with them until the end
of the show and so I just mean do not go
anywhere because the mothers of these
Cubs just mean want to get these Cubs is
some dinner at this age they have been
able to eat meat they have been eating
meat to be very exciting to see them
eating meat if these females here would
be successful initially they had seen a
warthog and they were like the meta
judgment and they found so what it and
they didn't go for it and they must be
seeing something that I cannot see and
I'm only guessing maybe this time is not
a warthog because in the kind of light
we have chances are it could be
something bigger and it could be maybe a
choppy alley I heard us in choppiness
disappeared somewhere so I do not know
what the ones in front watching these
two are with the Cubs and is slowly
following they're the first two females
and that tree there that's why the two
have gone
they are not very far from that tree
either they have crouched down in the
grass or they just somewhere where I
can't see them they would definitely
blend in very well they wouldn't want
the prey to see them
and my hope is they cut something for
themselves because I can tell if they
are hungry and they definitely need some
dinner tonight not knowing where the
other families and most likely they
might drug something to her if maybe she
has dropped
how come she goes 100% she cannot leave
them and either drops must be last night
of this morning because I wasn't with
her last night until about 8:30 o clock
should be idly twelve well I mean 24
hours ago and a lot could have happened
between that time and now look in the
movement of the 3rd Nile lioness that
tells you lots of communication between
her Twitter ahead and one of them might
stay got the just big-ass but you never
know sometimes they have left the cab's
moved the four or the five of them were
together and left in structures of the
cabs stay put and don't move
we'll call you if we need you just
walked she's crouching and that's the
stroking word to me and she just lay
down though yes and it couldn't be
better
this is just so cool and this is what so
far life is all about and our joy is
always to bring you such sightings which
also gives us a lot of joy to be able to
see this every day gives us lots of
happiness now what do you want to do the
Cubs are not as playful as before I have
been too slow maybe not just Paul hunt
this one is taking a different direction
this one is kinky if you look at L you
can see she got a split to the tail and
see how he stopped
she looked and of five females in this
pride she's always looking at her belly
and see how big it is definitely that is
not meeting it of course I got feeling
there's some Cubs in there I do not know
how many cats
got him there lionesses will get
anything one to four cubs the maximum I
have always known are four cubs but it's
always an average of one to two
occasionally three four is always a very
big number
now being the eldest she's very
experienced and you do not know what she
is telling the others the use of body
language and what you want to do now is
to move a little bit forward and try to
see what they could get a different
angle we do not want to get very close
we do not want to interfere with the
hunting but also we don't want to miss
any special moments because the two that
I can't see I do not know what they're
doing and I don't know where they are
but I think something could be happening
here as they do that let's take you back
to achieve with hosana
thanks David I hope the sausage tree
prod gets up to some action this
afternoon they were very flat last night
and well hopefully they managed to catch
something just before the end of the
show we do know there are very efficient
hunters and I do know that that areas
starting to dry up with game still
Buffalo around and probably some topi
but most of the bull the beasts have
moved off again and her son is not too
bothered about any of that right now he
is what we call a flatter cat this he's
got a little bit of a belly on him there
is his right front and left trunk which
is twitching at all but he's probably
replaying his Steinbach hunt what a
beautiful cat
his dreaming he likes dreaming he takes
off to his dad his dad is a serious Napa
trying to get comfortable you know that
feeling folks when you're just so
extremely hot II just can't quite find
the right position to move into with a
bit of respite though the Sun has gone
behind us and plants hello Keith know
when a leopard is panting heavily like
that that's basically to do with the
fact that he's warm and also to do with
the fact that he's digesting a lot of
protein inside his belly and when his
belly's full leopards and lions have the
ability to gorge themselves and when the
belly gets full what it does is it
pushes the diaphragm up and the
diaphragm then limits the amounts of
space that the lungs have to work so he
can't really take deep breaths it's all
shallow breaths because of the limited
movement inside so this is
characteristic of a leopard or a cat
that has eaten and also on a warm day
like this this is very very normal
a leopard that's stressed will be
showing signs of stress in the fact that
their body language will generally be
one of quite flat to the ground by
contact to be looking at whatever it is
that's a threat and looking a little bit
jumpy male leopards that interact with
each other drool a lot of sort of the
saliva their salivate Okumura last night
drooling incessantly and he sign of of a
stress and also testosterone build up
within the cat due to possibly some
conflict what exactly the purpose of the
saliva overed indulgence is really I'm
unsure of maybe someone up that can
inform me if they know why do male
leopards when they encounter each other
drool so much I really don't know it's
kind of like an anticipation of
something maybe it's got to do with
anticipation of a fight anticipation of
maybe needing more moisture in the mouth
because I'm becoming aggressive with
another male might require a little bit
more moisture more swallowing power may
have either saliva helps them to growl
so sort of lubricate their mouth and to
allow the internal bits of the mouth to
to vibrate a little bit more for example
you get a little bit of
parched mouth if you want to sing nicely
you need to drink some water so as to
lubricate just kind of assuming things
here maybe there is a more plausible
responsible answer there you can see his
left-hand side of the face now you see
the three spots there is well sorry mi
Reina wants to know about something
about leopard habitat I didn't get the
first part there Oh drats
so marina you want to know about your
arts if anything drafts improve leopard
hunting due to the fact that the
leopards feed on meat our drought
effects the vegetation and affects the
foliage to the grass layer and what that
does is it leads to animals losing
condition and an animal that's lost
condition is generally a little bit
easier to catch than an animal that is
in full full strength so what we saw I
didn't see it but early this year now it
was last year last year there was a
serious drought in the Buffalo some of
the Bulls that I found around with the
carcasses on the property enormous horns
those animals were so Amman ceated that
made it very easy work for the Lions to
catch so the drought actually improves
predators and the Predators pick off the
weak and the the not so fit and that is
part and parcel of sort of survival of
the fittest and the ones that survive
the drought then go on to breed the next
year but if anything droughts and times
of dryness and times of scarcity for
prey of food is definitely time that
predators such as a lion hyena and
leopard capitalise most certainly
well as it resets yet and the Sun slowly
hiding behind some clouds a little bit
of cool respite for us and David and the
Mara who's an hour ahead has already put
on his second layer of sugar well yes
stevia right is much colder here than it
is in in Juma because when we started it
was about 27 and maybe 80 degrees
Fahrenheit but I'm sure now we could be
doing maybe low twenties because they're
really cool oh no our cups are still
being very playful here and there's some
way on the right there and we cannot see
the pines because the parents have gone
further away so what we want to do is
just tell you the cards for a couple of
minutes and not to follow the adults or
the mothers very closely not to
interfere in whatever they could be
doing but you can see in this club's
here which we all know now they're boys
and you can tell when you look below the
table in particular and they're all
three boys so the two that are older
about four months and the young was born
three months on joy you would like to
know where Lions hunt
I mean hide their cubs they could hide
their cubs in Hawaii it could be in a
barrel
it could be next from a termite mound or
it could be in a hole or you know a
hollow tree or sometimes in between
rocks or grasses like this if these cabs
go flat here I can tell you you will not
see them and of course they got their
kind of communication and the parents or
the mothers can easily tell them stay
here and do not move so they should have
so many choices or so many places where
they can hide their cubs those are the
address there and I think I made now two
attempts to hunt the first one was a
warthog and this particular one was so
so two at hogs and either the wind was
growing or the windows in the favor of
the warthogs I don't think the what also
these lionesses but they just smelled
them
they just took off so they have to try
one more time just gonna sit together
and make a new plan now when we have the
migration I'm talking about 20 hub the
wildebeest and the Zebras around here
it's always a piece of cake for these
silly Onassis to hunt but once they are
gone it becomes a bit tricky and tight
for them to be able to look for prey and
they have to look for smaller prey like
you know what hogs model antelopes like
harvest all copies and occasionally they
look for the big and dangerous prey I'm
doing a buffaloes Albert you say this is
beautiful and it's stunning and Albert
just to see a lioness there with a green
plus plus the the sky there it makes it
so so colourful and unhappy Albert not a
great comment and just see that lioness
there let's find out where the other
ones are and especially the Cubs but
something tells me if not right Albert
look at that if not tonight then
tomorrow morning they must get some
dinner okay that's kinda Albert and I'm
sure you are but no the other wonderful
viewers are taking some wonderful
screenshots this is the beauty of the
Marva triangle and the trees you see
there we call them the tall trees very
iconic trees of the Mara one learner is
coming back after the failed attempt
second failed attempt to hunt watch OGG
so we're gonna be sitting together but
I'm sure before long they might surprise
us with another move now Sydney tell us
what you are up to
so what should happen another plan would
make oops what's running there well I
thought something is running but it was
just my own imagination I thought
whoever they catch it something now in
the background that you can see the
thick clouds are building and we have
been having some short rains in Kenya
but they have been hammering us every
other day but out saying this is the
sixth day straight without a single drop
of rain which is just wonderful
well rain is good when it comes it makes
the whole area here green which is good
for all the happy woods which translates
to wonderful time for the cuts look at
all the torture trees in the Mara and
how beautiful is that you imagine I see
this every other day
this is very exciting I'll skip staying
with my sausages here or with my
lionesses and their cabs to see what
other move they might be doing and do
not go away but meantime we'll take you
back to Steve with husana thanks David
well we are still in the same place now
I must apologize Dave has just reminded
me that I said a word quite incorrectly
moments ago I meant to say emaciated not
Amann ceated to apologize some really
big words coming out of my mouth today I
think I'm also a little bit hot like
Rosanna and little bit um well we're not
hungover but that feeling you get when
the that the Sun cooks your brain I do
apologize nothing has changed since you
were last here apart from it getting
slightly cooler
very gentle breeze started to pick up
hello child universe's masala has got a
preference I couldn't I couldn't narrow
it down to one species specifically
we've seen him with a mini day cap I'm
seen him with a number of Nala and
Impala yung yola though I haven't yet
seen him with a big in Halle I think
while I was in the Mara he managed to
get hold of whether he caught them or
not or if they were just pregnant
females that didn't do very well with
the drought
he had them anyway but I haven't seen
him yet with warthog no one that ah none
of the viewers I believe have seen him
yet with the warthog that's the the
experienced level you move up to a
warthog just like a male leopard or a
young female leopard becomes an adult
truly an adult when they are able to
take a fully grown male Impala because
well they are much bigger and stronger
than the females a little bit more
difficult to catch the Derby's just
catching some comb ducks as their flew
off if they go male also known as the
knob to build duck with a really big
sort of a knob on the end of the nose
which is still very strange to me why
they have such an interesting appendage
Linda from California he is always
dreaming I'd love to know what's going
on in this head and we all come up with
all sorts of theories and ideas but if
only we knew he's probably thinking
about all of the different impalas and
the honours and he's had a few Steinbach
as well I haven't seen him with many we
found him with a steam box this morning
I think that for me is the first
Steinbach I've seen him with but then
also how many scrub has has he caught we
have no idea and last year before I got
you
I mean used maybe it was the year before
he was quite young and he managed to
catch himself a monitor lizard that he
thoroughly enjoyed I think there was a
period as well when he went through a
stage of enjoying Terrapins maybe he
just thought that they were quite nice
in the beginning and slow-moving
or him with the Terrapin at voyeur
Telepan earlier this year that he
basically just played with for a while
and then let go and obviously realized
well Oh a little bit of a twitching
he's definitely having some form of
dream as emesis is probably counting in
parlors in parlor Lambs
fast asleep but that's the thing folks
is that he might seem fast asleep but
like any cat he's very alert ooh the
ears or twitching the nose is always
that was very from all times the nose is
able to smell and he's very alert to
whatever might be approaching but anyway
Sydney I think is back down at Chitra
watering hole and let's go and see what
exactly he's found you can see that I
have got a roller now for a David guitar
McGee too from Kenya
I have executed the instruction the
beautiful roll is right there look at
that this is quite a lovely bed and this
bed as I indicated is associated with
the marriages traditionally this is a
bed which can be able to solidify a
couple so during the wedding you just
have to hold each other's hand with a
feather of this bed in the middle that
is a symbol of an ever love lasting
relationship some of the tribes they're
even making some of the rings from these
birds they've got a very interesting
acrobatic flight when they are chiming
each other for breeding purposes and
another interesting part is they're
monogamous they are partners for life
maybe that is why they are used in order
to solidify couples so we are very lucky
to found this bed very much stationery
a cynic it is not uncommon that is very
much usual I have seen a leopard
catching a dove before leopards
they are so opportunity conscious and
they can just go for anything which
present itself where the bed insects
they also catch they we have got a
competition with them when it comes to
the swamps they a--let's the
reproductive of the termites when they
see them they also catch them so they
don't only consider eight on the big
animals they also catch Mongoose
I think asana has been seen as well
chasing Mongoose before so it's normal
leopard is like that don't only go for a
big animal if it's tough they can go for
something small so I'm just going to
carry on now I am still around the
cheetah cheetah
I'm just driving around yet to see if we
cannot be lucky with any of the
Predators coming to drink at the water
hole but I am NOT winning I'm gonna have
to head back to the waterhole and see
from there if we can find something
[Laughter]
chasing the small prey is interesting
not only the Mongoose CNET including the
scrub hairs if you see the leopard
chasing this club where is too
interesting those small animals trying
to use all the different anti-predator
strategies to confuse the big predators
so amazing so I must have to try by all
means and find something here in Perham
preparation of the s ABC show later on I
am going to try thank you very much for
all the comments I feel very much
inspired so I'm outside here maybe I'll
be lucky but it's good that my friend
Steve has got something and host David
I'm sure they might be having some Lions
for later on
oh here we've got another animal this is
so cute he's got very beautiful and
lovely horns look at that can you see
him there this is a beautiful water bug
look at that look at those ones and so
far I'm only just seeing in there I'm
not seeing the other group members look
at that look at those horns how big are
they and when it's looking forward you
can see the water bug is just now having
some of the fresh grasses these animals
they don't mark territories same like
other animals they don't use urine and
droppings they rely on their own body
odor in order to communicate for
territorial purposes they have got what
is called subcutaneous gland this land
they use it for waterproof and also to
warn the intruders about their level of
dominance in the area you can see there
by the neck is got a white beep the beep
and the hairs on the next they use this
kind of animal to stare others child of
the universe you can see this universe
is having those beautiful animals so
look at that so you can see as well the
white line at the back yeah it's very
rare to come across a water bug coming
much closer late now only now that is
trying to be inquisitive but I can
promise you he's gonna come pass here
he's trying to listen maybe it's not
concentrating on me
so while I am heading back to the
waterhole let's quickly go back to Steve
with our sauna thanks to this good luck
in your search that aside
no sauna is a flat cat well there has to
be marvelous
spending time within this afternoon he
has a graced us with his presence he did
what he's done it so many times in the
past
he sought seeked I kinda know what I'm
saying he looked for us he came to find
us because well he's quite a lonely
fellow we do know he likes to spend time
with his dad he likes to hang around -
he even tries to follow Tandy around and
well Davi was on the vehicle once with
Brent the renter's off the vehicle
looking for a sauna and Davi had the
camera frame like this and a sauna just
walks into frame going on yeah everybody
yeah that's practically what you did
with us now so it is always important to
follow predators in the mara David does
that as well you find the hyenas you
follow them you might find some lions
you might find lions and then you find
the hyenas afterwards
here is a very similar story and you
find a high unit you might find a lipid
and if you spend time long enough with a
leopard there's a very good chance
ie nurse will materialize in the area
because they love to smell them out and
there is huge competition between them
for food resource and regardless of how
efficient he is at hunting and catching
his prey horse owner still has to have
the necessary skills to tree the kill
witched Andy wasn't able to do the other
day and then lost that Impala on the
torch with cheetah Catlin boundary so
very very important for them to be able
to cash their food it is the strategy
that sees leopards dominate in areas
like this when they can't get their food
up the treat they really are very very
successful
well everybody thank you for joining us
this afternoon on a safari live we have
thoroughly enjoyed your questions and
comets to FC and all those in the Mara
thank you for assisting as well you'll
see it tomorrow morning bright and early
for another Safari have a beautiful
evening and good night